for cellular automata can can do
cognition if a plant can do cognition if
uh a xenobot can do cognition how do I
like whisper in its ear and and get an
answer back to how do I have a
conversation yeah
um well how do I have a xenobot on a
podcast it's really a really interesting
line of um investigation that that that
that opens up I mean I mean we've
thought about this so you need a few
things you need you need to understand
the space in which they live so uh what
not not just the physical modality like
can they see like can they feel
vibration I mean that's important of
course because that's how you deliver
your message but but not just not just
the the ideas for a communication medium
not not just the physical medium but
what is saliency right so so what are
these what what are important to this
what's important to this system and
systems of all kinds of different levels
of sophistication of what you could
expect to get back and I I think what's
what's really important I call this um
the the spectrum of persuadability which
is this this idea that when you're
looking at a system you can't you can't
assume where on the Spectrum it is you
have to do experiments and so so for so
so
uh for example uh if you look at a gene
regulatory Network which is just a bunch
of bunch of nodes that turn each other
on and off at various rates you might
look at that and you say wow there's no
magic here I mean clearly this thing is
uh is is as deterministic as it gets
it's a piece of Hardware the only way
we're going to be able to control it is
by rewiring it which is the way my
molecular biology works right we can add
nodes remove notes or whatever well so
we've done simulations and shown that
um biological and now we're doing this
in in the lab the biological networks
like that have have associative memory
so they can actually learn they can
learn from XP they have they have
habituation they have sensitization they
have associative memory which you
wouldn't have known if you assume that
they have to be on the left side of that
Spectrum so when you're going to
communicate with something and we've
even um uh uh Charles Abrams and I've
written a paper on um behaviorist
approaches to synthetic organism meaning
that if you're given something you have
no idea what it is or what it can do how
do you figure out what it's psychology
is what its level is what does it and so
and so we literally lay out a set of
protocols starting with the simplest
things that I'm moving up to more
complex things where you can make no
assumptions about what this thing can do
right just from you you have to start
and you'll find out so so when you're
gonna so so here's a simple I mean
here's one way to communicate with
something if you can train it
that's a way of communicating so if you
can provide if you can figure out what
the currency of reward of positive and
negative reinforcement is right and you
can get it to do something it wasn't
doing before based on experiences you've
given it you have taught it one thing
you have communicated one thing that
that such and such an action is good so
some other action is is not good that's
that's like a basic atom of a primitive
atom of communication what about
in some sense if it gets you to do
something you haven't done before is it
answering back yeah most most certainly
and there's there's I've seen cartoons I
think maybe Gary Larson or somebody had
had a cartoon of these of these rats in
the Maze and the one rat uh you know
assists to the other hey look at this
every time every time I walk over here
he starts scribbling in that on the you
know on the clipboard that he has it's
awesome if we step outside ourselves
and really measure how much like if I if
I actually measure how much I've changed
because of my interaction with certain
cellular automata and you really have to
take that it's a consideration about
like well these things are changing you
too yes I know you know how it works and
so on but you're being changed by the
thing absolutely I think I think I read
um I don't know any details but I I
think I read something about
um how how wheat and other things of
domesticated humans in terms of right
but by their properties change the way
that the human behavior and societal
structures in that sense cats are
running the world
because they they took over the first of
all so first they while not giving a
[ __ ] about humans clearly would ever
with with every ounce of their being
they've somehow got just millions and
millions of humans to to to to take them
home and feed them and then not only the
physical space that they take over they
took over the digital space they
dominate the internet in terms of
cuteness in terms of immutability
and so they're they're like they got
themselves literally inside the memes
they become viral and spread on the
internet
and they're the ones that are probably
controlling humans that's my theory
another that's a follow-up paper after
the frog kissing